okay she is the emmy nominated actor who
produced the aclu documentary the fight
which you can see in select cinemas on
video and on demand starting friday
july 31st that's tonight for those
watching tonight kerry washington
carrie thank you so much for doing this
my first question to you is did you feel
the
earthquake uh today and i don't mean the
thing that got me out of bed i mean that
trump said
trump said uh he tweeted that he wants
to delay the election
you're a thought leader in this country
now what is your reaction to that
um you know not to jump right into the
film but i do have to jump right into
the film because one of the things
that um that happened for me you know
i've always
had such a great deal of respect for the
aclu and have always
you know had a really good working
relationship with them but
what i came to realize is every single
thing that we are worried about right
now
lgbtq rights women's right to choose
police brutality on black bodies
immigrants rights
voting rights when you read something
horrible happening
in the paper you can be guaranteed
that the aclu is on it they are at the
forefront
of this fight of battling the attack on
civil rights and civil liberties so
my first response honestly when i read
it was like oh
i bet that dale hoe who runs the voting
rights division at the aclu is going to
drop out of some of our interviews for
the movie today because he has work to
do
and i'm grateful that he's on the ground
doing that work
right well they sure need defending the
aclu because they also
defend people who are abhorrent and
a lot and i think a lot of times on the
left
we forget about free speech in the
interest of
uh not being offended and
i think it's great that someone like you
gets out there and says yes the aclu was
our friend even though they defended the
nazis in skokie
they defended people at charlottesville
they they
defended the westboro baptist church i
mean they
walk the walk they really do you know
people i try to remind people that there
hasn't ever been a president since the
inception of the aclu a hundred years
ago there's never
been a president who hasn't been sued
they've sued every president republican
or democrat
um because they really aren't invested
in the rights of all people
but i'm also i'm very proud of how we
deal with the whole charlottesville
situation in the film
we really um we ask them about it we
we are invited into their introspection
and they're doing a lot of
conversations within the organization
right now around
where they stand um and making sure that
they're also factoring in
access to power when they choose their
clients you know they believe in free
speech but when they
decide which clients they will work with
um
they're they're having really
complicated nuanced conversations about
that and we were able to capture some of
that for the film which i'm really proud
of yeah well you should be it's a great
film and i hope everybody gets a chance
to see it
uh in some platform and we have lots of
time to do that so you should see that
that's right
that's right i know i know everybody's
watching black is king this weekend i am
too
but when you're done with black king
then you can watch the fight
okay so uh it was uh john lewis's
funeral today
um uh aaron this show airs tomorrow but
it was today and i know you
knew him you must have had a lot of
thoughts and
emotions and uh president obama spoke of
course to know in surprise he was great
bill clinton spoke george bush spoke
not someone you'd expect but to me
i thought that was a good sign in
america we have to
i did too you did too i did i really did
i felt like
um you know this idea of being able to
have conversation
across the aisle the idea of respect and
civility
um we are talking at each other
and not with and to each other and um
and that is not how we're going to get
to real change in this country
but you know there are people who will
say well it's it's not right because
george bush's father
did the willie horton ad and george bush
you know was
not a great friend of the
african-american
what do you say to that um i get it
i get it but i think that
it's funny like it's funny how how you
know things can seem rosy when you're
when you're faced with with new
circumstances
when it comes to presidents but i
marched you know i protested
bush's presidency i protested the war
i protested the cuts to federal funding
for the arts i
still think that when a great civil
rights leader
passes and somebody from the other side
of the aisle
says i want to come and show respect
that that
is something that i welcome and i
welcome it because
we have to restore the voting rights act
and and i want to be in conversation
with legislative officials with elected
officials who are
willing to step outside their comfort
zone to do what is right for all people
and just staying away and keeping this
huge divide
is not how you guarantee rights for all
americans
yeah i think that's a great point also
about we
with trump we have perspective now you
know
about people we don't agree with fully
but you know it doesn't it doesn't
really help anything to point fingers
and say you're not
you're not nearly as good as me so you
know you have to just be banished but
okay
so uh joe biden he says announced the
other day that uh
he is going to choose his vice president
uh
in the coming week and we may find out
who that is very soon after
uh any thoughts on that uh what
who is who was your druthers choice
who do you think it's gonna be i think
it's gonna be kamala harris
you do oh absolutely i mean she i mean
for
a a number i i would bet any money i
have left which is very little now after
they took away
half my way to make a living and oh you
don't even want to know the stories but
uh
uh yeah um i think it's going to be
kamala harris i mean she's a
law and order prosecutor that answers a
lot of
what trump is trying to sell on his side
about
unrest in the streets and she's a black
woman and i i just think she's
and i like her i think she's good i mean
she made some mistakes in the campaign
but
i think she's good yeah i agree i think
that would be an excellent choice i
think kamala would be an excellent
choice i think stacey abrams would be an
excellent susan rice was on our show
she'd be great
yeah i love her yeah i love her these
are really really
powerful strong women well we love you
as i said to you before we started you
keep getting to be a bigger star but you
keep doing our show which i can't say
for all the big stars out there
like joe biden used to do our show then
he became vice president he forgot all
about us but you are true blue i thank
you
so much congratulations on your ten emmy
nominations yesterday
and uh good luck with the film thank you
so much
thank you so much